Speaker 1: Let's go to Jonathan from
Ohio. Jonathan from Ohio. Welcome to
the program. What can I do for
you today? What's on your mind?
Oh, boy. Jonathan from Ohio, Please select the
correct audio device so that we can hear you.
And last chance for Jonathan from Ohio.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me now?
Speaker 1: I can hear you, sir.
Speaker 4: Hello, sir.
Speaker 1: How are you?
Speaker 4: Thank you for taking my call.
My pleasure. This is more. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you.
Speaker 4: Okay. This is more
something that happened in Ohio that I would like
to make people aware of. Okay. So apparently they
defined natural gas as a clean energy source now.
Oh, really? In Ohio, it's defined as clean energy,
similar to other types of renewable energy.
And I just wanted to make people aware of that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this just happened. So for people
who don't know, new law signed into law, signed in
by Governor Mike DeWine, designates natural gas
as green energy, that is absolutely insane. And
I guess the point of it, you tell me, Jonathan,
you might know more about it. It paves the way to
fast track drilling of oil and gas in state parks.
Speaker 4: That's correct. For actually working?
Yeah. I work in the natural gas industry and there
is a lot of fields like in the eastern part of the
state that are trying to get to. So it does it's
really bad for like climate change, obviously.
And they're trying to set a standard for other
states to do this kind of thing. And I just think
people should be aware of this and
not let it go down the slippery slope.
Speaker 1: Yeah, like burning natural gas is not
green. That I hope people understand that. Now,
Jonathan, you work in an industry that you think
is bad for the environment, it sounds like.
Speaker 4: Yes. I mean, like it's like the
safety side of it to make sure people, you know,
they don't leak or Yeah, you know, events don't
occur. So I'm on that side of it, but. My hope
is that the industry migrates to renewables. My
company at least is trying to do that. But I just
thought it was good information to be aware of.
Speaker 1: 100%. Yeah. I mean, when you when we
think about renewable and green, it is certainly
not natural gas. I appreciate you bringing it
to my attention, Jonathan.
Speaker 4: Yeah, for sure.
Speaker 1: All right. Jonathan from Ohio
delivering some unfortunately depressing news